makes you think you know at what point
is the
pressure
you know at a place where you're willing
to make the move rather than staying
there when i asked jordan peterson i
said jordan i said why are you staying
in toronto so he says you know i'm still
staying in toronto because of different
reasons i said are you staying in
toronto because one day you want to run
for prime minister no i have no desire
why don't you want to run if you think
you can well no i think i can do
more of an impact doing what i'm doing
versus being a prime minister i said i
don't know about that i said listen
philosophers great will stick around but
you know i think prime minister
presidents those guys are going to be
you know somebody that's going to be
remembered do you think jordan would
make a good pm in canada if you chose to
want to do that i think he's too honest
i i've been also asked to run for high
office and so i'll speak for me but i
think it applies to to your question
about jordan i think
all of the qualities that a politician
needs to have duplicity uh scamming
cheat uh machiavellianism i don't think
jordan and i scored very highly on those
so i think we would be chewed up in five
seconds again i don't want to speak for
him but
for me
i don't think i could function in that
ecosystem and so i think i agree with
with jordan that our voices are probably
uh more influential doing what we do
here because the political system will
simply squash you into you know saying
what they want you to say and i don't
think jordan or myself are willing to
play that so in other words we have to
uh put up with what's being given to us
in regards to politicians that's what we
have to deal with so so maybe we need to
stop complaining about corrupt
politicians because we
the good people don't want to run is
that the right solution
as you remember you might remember plato
talked about philosopher kings right
that democracy was too important to be
given to the common person you needed
the philosophers to run things and so
that's i think what you're talking about
it should be someone like jordan
peterson who's running the country but
regrettably in today's world people like
jordan peterson uh are too honest to
succeed in such a parasitic world and by
the way i remember that conversation
right here a few months ago you you you
asked that question multiple times so
have you considered and then you
revisited it but you know why though you
know why i'm asking that question
because
if if you if if the people
that the people wouldn't mind running
don't run
then you lose the right to complain
about the corrupt people who do yeah so
you don't have the right to complain
about it
because
i don't know if you understand what i'm
saying so so we're sitting there so okay
look at these guys they're saying
something about it yeah no it's it's
either
run
and create some real change and policies
or
don't run and stop complaining about the
people that are corrupt and just say
justin's a great guy
okay and he's the best guy that we got
today but you to me i may be wrong you
can't do both let's see you you can't
sit there now listen i'll give you the
uh flip side of it as well
the other side of it for me would be the
following here's the flip side of it
if jordan peterson or somebody in this
situation we're just using jordan but
pick anybody you know whoever that uh
has that kind of influence right
if a jordan peterson-esque type of an
individual said no i'm not running no
problem why don't you create an academy
and go
work with the current 25 year olds
and prepare them for the next year 10
years
so they can run for office and teach
them all the machiavellian stuff that
they're gonna go through
have them read prints have them read 40
laws of power have them read
all the stuff that's going to happen and
give them strategies challenge them push
them put them against each other pin
them against each other give them a
topic to play for it against it argue
against it something they believe in but
argue how the other person would argue
against it and then try to find the
leaks and here's liz and look at this
article look how this person handled
this debate then shape their mindsets 10
years from now so then in 10 years you
got a roster of 20 people that can run
but to me it's one of the two didn't you
say obama did something like that you
remember
speaking at ritz exactly 2 000 african
american kids in the early 20s good
looking men like i'm talking and the way
they spoke i'm like you just sound like
you could run you said they were sharp
everybody was sharp so i go into sneak
peek i'm like oh my god
fire imagine 2000 barack obama's and
michelle in the room
and i said what's going on here i said
well this is uh michelle and brock are
going to be here this is an organization
that's helping develop the next
african-american leaders that may one
day become
leaders of the free world and presidents
but they were lawyers there's a lot of
lawyers in that room so you know what i
said i said good for you that's what
you're supposed to do okay so there's
not a you know this whole concept with
the academy the book that i'm you know
publishing right now that we're going
through
um
we though the people like that can do
such a great job in because there is one
thing to do videos and we're glued to
the screen and somebody watches oh my
god god you oh wow what a great argument
okay so this is the satire approach if
you want to go this angle great oh my
god look at this jordan peterson crate
but then there is
all right come into the room close the
door get rid of all the cameras leave
your phones outside let's talk
here's how you handle this
there's difference between that and that
group
what you're talking about used to be
called universities right i mean
right i mean the way we train people in
critical thinking and in debate skills
and in evidence-based decision-making we
used to be called the university and in
a sense that's what i've been railing
against for the past you know almost 30
years we had these institutions right
and you know
when i first started my career
i'm not sure if we discussed this when i
first came on your show remotely
so what i do is i apply evolutionary
biology and evolutionary psychology to
study human behavior right
well when i saw how social scientists
would respond to my work where they
didn't like the fact that i'm applying
biology right biology was great to
explain the behavior of the mosquito and
the zebra and the dog but what do you
mean you're applying biology to explain
consumer behavior what are you some kind
of nazi and so that's when i first was
exposed to this idea that even very
educated people my fellow professors
could be parasitized by stupidity and so
that really was the genesis of how i
eventually wrote the parasitic mind
because originally it started in my
scientific career where i would see
these incredibly brilliant people
who would completely lose it at what i
thought was a terribly banal point which
is of course humans are driven by their
hormones by their physiology i mean who
doesn't think that that's feasible but
yet in the social sciences we have
erected these edifices of of
of knowledge for the past hundred years
completely devoid of any biology so you
could study anthropology sociology
economics you could be in the business
school where i'm housed and the word
biology is never mentioned once but how
could you study things like economic
decision making employee psychology
employer psychology consumer psychology
without ever mentioning biology so
you know the things that you're hoping
for the academy that you're looking for
we used to be called the university and
i'm hoping that we will return regain
the power of the university because
we've truly lost it
i i
i don't know i don't know if it's gonna
go back to that
uh but i i think what
could happen a lot
is if individual academies are created
yeah
i think if individual academies are
created and by the way that's when
uh uh you you go you'll go and talk to
like let's just say the syrian community
i'm a syrian right we're talking your
wife is armenian i'm armenian so we're
talking armenian and i like how your
wife was translating everything i was
saying she's like this is what he means
he just said this his mother's armenian
his dad's a syrian please go ahead tell
the people how beautiful she is go ahead
no
listen you look you're you're a very
good-looking guy and i told you that you
look like you're omar sharif type of you
know guy that's got to be in hollywood
your wife's dropped it gorgeous she's
beautiful so good for you
congratulations on you guys by the way
that uh that was your birthday gift
sweetie from last week you just you just
got a huge shout out from patrick david
that's your gift she's beautiful it was
great meeting here no but so so you're
sitting there and you're thinking like
this whole thing with academy right
and you're saying okay what if what if
you know she's a syrian you know
armenian where they're talking i'm
talking to these assyrian folks and they
run a church or they run the club the
syrian community
and will go in there and you'll all of a
sudden say like no well you guys are
kids and you don't know what you're
talking about listen why don't you
create an academy
and develop the next leaders that are
coming up
and and teach them history ritual teach
them stuff that work teach them the
50 biggest mistakes syrians made and
what we can do to learn from it right
hey what are the biggest mistakes a
candidate has made a republican
candidate a democratic candidate
i don't know if that's taking place
where those leaders are being developed
like i asked uh uh
is not not hillsdale college it is
hillsdale college but you got heritage
foundation you got hillsdale college you
got some of these places that are out
there okay what are you doing to develop
the next guys that are coming up okay
charlie kirk is doing turning point usa
and it's growing fantastic
but i'm more talking about doors closed
you know i've developed leaders but i've
given tens of thousands of speeches in
the last 20 years
take any of those speeches that i've
given
and then
ask who i've built the most it was a lot
of small group setting one on one one on
five one and ten one in 20 where it's
like sitting there going
that's where real development is made so
if you don't want to run for prime
minister no problem why don't we create
an academy where you take the next 50
100 guys that are out there and every
year create a one week camp kind of like
how michael jordan does his one-week
camp kyrie irving's got us all these
basketball players have their own camps
that you go to every summer yeah great
why don't you create a two-week camp
every summer i guarantee you there's
parents out there that would spend the 5
000 10 000
for their kids to spend time with you
and maybe there's going to be an element
of here's five ten thousand dollars i'm
gonna send my kid to be with you for two
weeks
but it's gonna be all day every day and
then if the parents wanna also be there
that's another five thousand dollars for
the parents they sit all the way in the
back they're not involved so your kids
are in the front you see the curriculum
so you know how to follow up with your
kids but you're in the back there's a
glass or whatever so you're not getting
involved and messing it up and he's
doing whatever he's doing with the kids
pinning them against each other debate
topic what do you think about this what
do you think about that read this really
really going through this intense
environment
i don't know if that exists today but if
it did exist and it was by people like
this
i think it would blow up and not only
blow up the future leaders would be
built coming out of many of these places
can i give a counter argument do so well
because i'm going to go back to
gad sad's initial argument is why would
i sit down in a classroom
with 30 people when i can go on to a
youtube or a webinar whatever and get 30
000 people on there so it kind of comes
down to your motivation and how many
eyeballs you want and is the money the
the the motivating factor is it is it
change is it creating something the
vision that you want
i'm throwing this to you because you
said at the onset of this conversation
why would i sit down and do a lecture in
a classroom when i could just do it on
youtube for me look
an academic has two it's a two-step
process number one you have to create
knowledge and i do that of course
through writing books through writing
academic papers but then the second part
is disseminating knowledge right i
because by the way do you know how what
is the average number of times that an
academic paper is cited in the in the
academic literature can you guess how
much
zero
the the the mean number of times
meaning that on average most academic
papers are cited by no one i mean you do
all this work and zero people give a
[ __ ] zero people give a [ __ ] exactly now
not all papers some papers are started
ten thousand times and that person
becomes you and far between i'm just
doing it exactly the average person is
producing garbage and again i'm not
denigrating academia but academics come
in different shades right some are very
very influential most do research that's
only read by their mom and the reviewer
right
and i've mentioned this story many times
before uh
but it's worth repeating so in 2017 i
had been invited to stanford business
school so that's pretty much the mecca
of prestige you know in academia i was
giving a talk on one of my scientific
papers and the gentleman who took me out
the uh the host is a fellow professor
and the night before we went out to
dinner and so at one point he asked me
says well you know i didn't know you
were such a you know academic celebrity
you hang out with joe rogan you go on
joe rogan i said yeah you know it's
great he said so he says it now look
with the kind of an air of disgust the
hottie here yeah well you know at
stanford we don't condone that i said
you don't condone what exactly he said
well you know we don't do research so
that could be sexy enough so so that we
can talk about it on joe rogan i said
well i don't do research i could appear
on joe rogan but surely it's better to
both do great research and be able to
discuss it on joe rogan because now 20
million people will see it yeah well we
don't we don't do that at stanford so
look at the mindset his mindset was i
only speak to a few of my anointed class
colleagues right i don't speak to the
great unwashed the rubes right whereas
for me an opportunity to come on pat's
show where i can reach millions of
people i'm jumping on that because i
don't have that elitism right i want now
there's kids who are going to be
listening to us hey i want to be that
next guy so in a sense i agree with both
of your positions we can do it
intimately with 20 people but we could
also do it with two million people on
pat's show well can you speak to the
mindset of the professor because i'm
going back to this like coffee task
force so i assume it got implemented and
there's coffee at your college but when
you walk into the break room in the
coffee room and there's you and a dozen
other professors what's the overall
sentiment like oh there's the [ __ ]
hot shot totally what is that vibe so
look as you probably know the seven
deadly sins include envy as one of the
sins right we also know from the ten
commandments don't covet
and so so envy regrettably is
it might it drives the economy right
keeping up with the joneses all those
[ __ ] next door have that fancy car i
want that fancy car so envy is driving
me to so what happens to a lot of my
colleagues is what's called an ego
defensive strategy they can't go on
pat's show
because they're not interesting and
charismatic enough but they know how to
write academic papers in a certain model
in a certain template they have mastered
that ability but they would love to go
on joe rogan but they can't pull it off
therefore they'll denigrate those who
can do it right so i'm a sellout right
because if i were really a haughty
professor i would only be publishing in
the top academic paper journals but
here's the thing i do publish in the top
academic journals so they can't hold
that against me so i do both but to them
you're a sellout for coming on pat's
show that's too vulgar it's for the
masses what's the phrase the those that
can't do teach yeah right how do you
process that
look i i don't i don't think it's true i
mean i think it's a bit of a
misnomer to say that only those who
can't do teach because
uh
you know if you study criminal behavior
and you're a criminologist should you
have been a corrections officer or a
criminal or so there are certain
scientific principles that you could
apply so i could teach entrepreneurship
even though i may not have been a great
entrepreneur myself so i don't
necessarily buy that but it is true that
academia because of the slowness of how
things move
breeds a bit of a parasitic uh culture a
deadwood culture so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]